in the last video i talk about how
there's multiple ways to define return
on asset this is given in some textbooks
and on some maybe some professors would
give this in in a finance class net
income divided by assets if you look on
wikipedia they say it's net income plus
interest minus tax savings from interest
so notice they're not adding back all of
the the taxes or they're they're still
taking in taxes into consideration but
they're saying you're not getting any
tax deduction from your interest so
we'll talk about that in a second so
this kind of still does factor in taxes
this one definitely does and interest as
well
and then there's these two other ones
which one was operating profit divided
by asset which is what i gave in the
first video really just as kind of a
simplifying assumption and really to
give you the intuition in my mind of
what roa really is about of what are you
how good is a company at operating its
assets and actually getting a return
from them and then a slightly more
general
definition would be ebit divided by
assets and we talk about the fact that
ebit is just net income plus interest
plus taxes or another way to think about
it it's operating profit
plus non-operating profit so any other
type of
profit that the company might have
gotten from from from some assets that
it owns that actually aren't essential
to actually managing the business but
then i in the last part of the video i
talked about you know you have these
definitions out here but i don't like
using them as much and then i ran out of
time and i said i would cover in this
video why i don't like using it as much
and i think the best way to talk about
it is with an example
so let's say i have two companies
two companies
okay company
now let me i want to do thicker lines
so okay so i have one company here
say they have the same amount of assets
so that's one company and then this is
the other company right here that i'm
trying to draw the left-hand side of
their balance sheets
so these are the assets
assets
now let's say that
this guy right
and let's say they're the same amount so
let's say they have 10 million dollars
of assets
10 million dollars and let's say that
company that this guy
let's say this these are the actual roas
is the way i calculated them so this is
your e-bit divided by
divided by total assets right so if ebit
is ten percent of this that that means
that this guy
is spitting out
ten percent
which would be
one million dollars of ebit
right
and in a world where there are no
non-operating profit this you could view
as operating profit remember ebit is
just earnings before interest and taxes
right let's go back to that income
statement that we started off with ebit
is earnings before interest and taxes so
if you add back interest and taxes you
essentially get back to operating profit
unless there is a little bit of non
operating profit right here so that's
the way to think about ebit for most
functional purposes unless you're
talking about like a financial most
firms that aren't doing anything too
fancy on their non-operating side of
their balance sheet even an operating
profit are pretty close to each other
but anyway in this case this guy is
generating one million dollars of ebit
and let's say that this company company
b
let me mark label this is company a this
is company b company b
it's generating 15 percent
of it's getting a 15 ebit return on its
assets so it's generating
1.5 million
in ebit per year
so just when i look at the left-hand
sides of the balance sheet i haven't
drawn the right-hand sides yet i would
say that this guy is a better manager of
these assets he's better at extracting
value given the amount of capital that
has been put into this company so that's
why i like the definition of ebit
divided by assets
or
operating profit divided by assets
now
let's say that this guy
well let's give a situation where you
know this this guy has very little debt
right
this guy has very little debt
let's say he has no debt
and he has all equity so
the right-hand side of his balance sheet
looks like this
let's say he has no
liabilities of significance
so liabilities
liabilities right here oh sorry he has
no liabilities of significance so this
is all equity
all equity
so when you when you want to figure out
this guy's
pre-tax income you take ebit
minus
minus actually let me move the window
down a little bit
you take ebit minus interest
right to get pre-tax so how much pre-tax
does he have pre-tax earnings well he
has no debt right
so he has no interest so his pre-tax
earnings or you could call it which no
one else ever does ebit
which you don't want to say because it
sounds like ebit but earnings before
taxes no one ever says ebt they always
say pre-tax but that would also be
one million dollars
right
and then if you go even further and you
say you know what this guy for some
reason he just he had a bunch of tax
credits this year or he was able to
he had some losses last year that he was
able to offset to use against his taxes
so this year he also didn't have to pay
any taxes right so his earnings
his earnings or his net income
is also
one million dollars
right fair enough
so this guy has a ten percent
ebit return on his assets but he's
earning but his earnings or his net
income is also this one million dollars
now let's say this guy over here he has
a little bit more debt on his balance
sheet let's say it's similar to the
first example we did so let me draw that
so let's say he has
let's say he has five million dollars of
debt
but the amount isn't what's necessarily
the most important thing so he has five
million dollars of debt or liabilities
liabilities could be other things as
well it could be you know he owes
pension liabilities or who knows what
else so he has five million dollars debt
but the important thing is he has
interest right so every year let's say
he has to pay 500 000 in interest 500
000 in interest he's paying 10 interest
on the on his debt 10 of 5 million is
500 000 so his pre-tax so if you took
let's do the bottom part of his balance
sheet balance sheet his ebit his
earnings before interest and taxes
is 1.5 million but then if you want to
subtract out interest
interest
you'd subtract out minus 0.5 million 500
000
and so his pre-tax
pre-tax is going to be
1 million
right
and now this guy also you know so so so
essentially the equity holders before
paying taxes equity here he has five
million of equity
this guy had 10 million right here
and like this is pre-tax and he has to
pay the 30 percent like we did in the
previous example just say 30 percent on
taxes so his net income
his net income will be seven hundred
thousand dollars right because he has a
million dollar pre-tax he has to pay
three hundred thousand in taxes so he
has a seven hundred thousand
net income
now let's look at how
what we would get in terms of an roa if
we did it using this definition
that some textbooks will give you
for the first guy his net earnings are 1
million dollars
and his assets were 10 million so by
this definition up here
company a has a 10 percent roa
by that definition over here this guy
made 700 000 of net income off of 10
million dollars
so he is going to be making an roa of
what 700 000 divided by 10
is 7
so now if you just look superficially
these numbers as defined by this ratio
right here you'll say oh this guy
company a has a better return on asset
he's better at managing his assets and
you know that that's completely false
company a was getting a much lower
return ebit return on his assets he was
only getting 10 percent this guy was
getting 15 percent company a was just
better at one it didn't have any debt
and it was also better maybe this year
avoiding paying taxes so
when you talk about roa it's very you
know there are other ratios that start
factoring in is how good is a company at
you know at financing its assets and how
good as a company is at
paying taxes efficiently which is just
another way of evading as many taxes as
possible
but but that's a separate ratio return
on asset to me says
what does a company do with the
left-hand side of the balance sheet and
when you do that when you do the net
income version you're factoring things
in like interest and taxes and then
you're muddying up the picture you're
not telling me which company is better
at actually giving a return just on its
assets not how it actually pays for its
assets
this
this definition that wikipedia gives and
it's good to be aware of all of them
because i don't want you to watch these
videos and said oh no you know sal said
it's operating profit divided by asset
or ebit divided by asset it's good to
know these so that you don't that these
aren't unfamiliar terms to you what i'm
telling you is that this definition or
this definition is more of a of a real
uh intuitive sense of what a company is
doing with this assets while these are
kind of textbook definitions this one
attempts to add back interest it adds
back interest so that it definitely it
wouldn't just the interest part between
this company and this company it won't
differentiate between the two but this
one does take into account which company
is good or bad at paying taxes and i
realize i'm out of time in the next
video maybe i'll talk a little bit more
in depth about the the tax savings from
interest because that's an interesting
concept right there but i think i'm
getting a little bit into the weeds now
because i want to kind of get back high
level and give you an overarching view
of how you can think about investments
and price to earnings and whatever else
i'll focus back on that on the next
video see you soon